this information is from north east
derbyshire district council
north east derbyshire district council
is proud to announce
that it will have
an engagement event for deaf people who
are residents in that area
in northeast derbyshire
this follows
them signing the bsl charter
in september 2019
where the council committed to all five
pledges
this event will be an opportunity for
deaf residents
to come together
at
drumfield
leisure centre
the event will showcase leisure services
with staff presenting information
about their leisure services what they
provide and how people can be involved
there will also be an opportunity for a
tour of the leisure centre
as well as asking questions of the
this event will highlight the positive
steps that the council's done
after signing the bsl charter
to
improve and assist deaf residents
at the event there will also be a
present presentation from sound
solutions
demonstrating their video relay service
the account has now agreed this
at its leisure centers
and head office
at wingerworth
which means deaf people
or deaf customers are able to contact
them
via sign language interpreters
this event will be held on friday the
8th of july
from half past 12 to 3 p.m
at drum field leisure centre
that is the civic center
in dronfield
the postcode
is s
18
1
p d
when you arrive at the event there will
be a light buffet available
between half past 12 and 1.
at the event there will be a bsl
interpreter available
if you have any questions
or any special requirements
please contact
amar
bashir
his email address is
a a m a r dot b a s h i r
at
n e hyphen
d d e r b y s h i r e dot gov dot u k